to get started I just wanted to ask you
both to introduce yourself we're really
fortunate today to have two second-year
students with us Petra Weiss and Mike
ding thank you again for joining us
could both of you talk a little bit
about your backgrounds how did you come
to the GSB why did you decide to pursue
an MBA and what were you doing before
you came here sure
yeah so I'll should I start yeah please
great so I am Petra for those of you who
didn't know I'm Petra and I worked at
Google before Business School and while
I was there I sort of realized that I
had this gap in people management skills
and that was sort of my reason for for
wanting to go back to business school
and so as I was looking at schools I was
trying to find a school that aligned
with that goal it's the one that focused
on coaching and interpersonal dynamics
and really building out those people
management skills and as I learned more
and more about the GSB I saw that that
was almost a perfect match and so I
decided to go to business school after
about three years in the in the working
world to build out those skills and to
to go back into a management role post
business school great thank you
sure yeah everyone my name is Mike dang
I'm the second year MBA before Stanford
I worked in private equity and venture
capital investing in technology
companies in San Francisco so in terms
of coming to business school I think one
reason why I decided to come is my first
job out of college I actually had a
manager who was a Stanford MBA grad and
the place where I worked was not the
most touchy-feely severn place and you
know people tended to be very aggressive
there wasn't a lot of mentorship that
the type of leadership was very
different from what we're taught at the
GSB and one thing that really inspired
me in my first employer was was how this
guy took a very active interest in my
development and he led in a way that was
very motivational inspiring very
empathetic and
I just really respected him I admired
the way that he managed and I wanted to
learn how to do that as well and he
actually encouraged me to apply to the
GSB and was actually one of my
recommenders as well awesome that's
great that actually brings up a question
that one of you is asking online about
the alumni network so you worked with
you know someone in the GSB community
pre-mba how have you leverage that
network currently and that goes for both
of you whether it's through internships
or general mentorship sure I can talk a
little about that so I have worked at a
number of firms that have been led by
led by Joe Spears so the firm of the
private equity firm I work before
business school was founded by a
geosphere I worked at investment firm in
New York over this summer that was also
founded by his spear and in each case
when I received an offer from these
places you know throughout the process
I'd actually been able to contact these
individuals because they were affiliated
with the GSB because they took an active
interest in students who were interested
in the GSB or were currently attending
the GSB
and and in each case I think you know
the application process itself was
already very much helped by the fact
that I was a part of the GSB Network but
even while I was there I think because I
came from Stanford because you know the
founders of these firms were Stanford
grads it enabled me to connect with them
much more easily than than someone who
may have not have had that shared shared
background yeah yeah and just and
building on that I think being at the
GSB I've used the alumni network a huge
amount so for for for those of you who
don't know we have a joint degree
program in education and business and so
while I know I want well I knew I wanted
to go back into people management after
I wasn't sure exactly whether that would
fall into the education space or the
tech space and so I have done probably
about a hundred informational interviews
with folks both at the GSB on the staff
and also alumni who have gone into all
SEC
ters of education so EdTech higher ed
and and charter schools and and
basically everything and have have used
those informational z-- to really help
me figure out where I belonged in those
two fields and so I think the alumni has
been hugely helpful in getting me to
where I am and helping me figure out
what's next for me yeah that is huge Wow
so you talked a little bit about doing
exploration in the MBA program pivoting
a little bit from where you were before
what was the cost-benefit that you
thought about coming into an mba program
was it hard to step out of the workplace
you know what were the opportunity cost
but you thought about and especially
when it came to either family or maybe
significant others sure yeah I think
there were a couple of big opportunity
costs for me the first I would say is
that my trajectory at the Google where I
was before school was was looking
positive and so it was really hard for
me to just to say if I do want to come
back and be a manager in tech why am I
really taking this time out now when
when it looks like I could get to where
I want to get just by staying staying at
Google but a lot of my mentors and a lot
of actually folks at Google that I
worked with had taken those two years
and sort of reinforced the interpersonal
and coaching skills that you can't you
simply can't get or invest in in the
same way while you're working and so I
figured for me it was really important
to go back early under three years
before that opportunity cost got too
high for me to sort of restart my career
a little bit and then again also I think
because I wanted to explore education as
well it seemed like a good time to
really decide do I continue to invest in
the tech space or an or not so it seemed
like an opportunity cost but when I
stepped back didn't feel like as much of
one it seems like going early would sort
of reduce that and then I would say the
second big thing is my fiancee lives in
New York City and so that was a big
decision because I had the opportunity
to move with Google to New York City and
be with him or obviously come to
Stanford and be
be a part and so I think that that was
definitely a huge huge consideration but
the GSB has a fantastic significant
significant other network and has really
brought him in he's actually really good
friends with Mike now through the GSB so
he's been extremely welcomed into this
community and he actually has had lots
of interviews with GSB alums that I've
set up for him through the alumni
network as well
I actually quick story emailed about ten
people in real estate in New York City
on his behalf and all ten replied so
just another story about the power of
the alumni network and yes it's an
opportunity cost but I think we'll be
stronger for having had the exposure
we've had while here that's great so
speaking of the exposure you've had
while you're here I was wondering if
each of you could talk a little bit
about the academic experience Mike if
you want to start with maybe a favorite
class or an experience that stands out
to you specifically around the academics
sure sure well as I mentioned before one
of the reasons why I came to business
school was to really learn how to be
this type of inspirational motivational
leader that my first manager was coming
out of college and I think the GSB does
an incredible job of giving you sort of
real-life experience quote unquote real
life but expert experiential learning
opportunities to do that and one class
that I will remember as the most
impactful class that I had was
interpersonal dynamics also known as
touchy feely which is a class where you
really explore how you react to other
people but also how you come off to
other people and you know I would say
before the GSB I was always very afraid
to truly open up to people about how I
felt how they made me feel what my
impact was on them what their impact was
on me but this is a sort of class that
creates a safe space for people to
really ask those tough questions of each
other and give each other honest
feedback about those impacts and so I
would say that the experiential learning
especially through classes like
touchy-feely has been the just the most
amazing part of the academic curriculum
here Patrick can you expand a little bit
on that what proportion would you say of
classes kind of break down different
teaching styles how much time would you
spend on cases versus lecturers versus
experiential learning and a little bit
more on the tactical side is it hard to
get electives or do you get to take the
classes that you want sure yeah so I
would say first year was more lecture
and case based for me and I feel free to
jump in if you disagree but first year
was it was probably about half and half
so for some of my classes like strategy
we we were in a case based format for
others like accounting it was a little
bit more lecture based although there
were some cases that were that we're
done and so the professor's basically
decided what would be the best way for
folks to learn the material that were
teaching and the most effective way so
that was mostly about half and half for
the elective second-year a lot more of
them have been experiential for me
because again I've been focusing on
coaching and interpersonal dynamics and
I'm part of a program called called
Arbuckle fellows and so that shift
second-year has been mostly to
experiential and then still still some
lecture and case base mixed in but
probably about 60% experiential and the
rest
Kayson and lecture based ok great so you
mentioned Arbuckle leadership fellows
maybe you can talk a little bit about
what that is and then both of you can
also add on other extracurriculars that
you're involved with in other
commitments that you have outside of
coursework in school and also how much
time you actually do spend on homework
and classes relative to that sure yeah
so Arbuckle fellows is a coaching
program that was started I want to say
about 10 years now but I'm not exactly
sure if that's the right date and
basically it allows the second year
class to coach and lead the first years
through what we call leadership labs
which is a first year required class in
your first quarter that allows you to
think about what kind of leader you want
to be if you're the kind of leader you
aren't how do you get there learning
from other leadership styles that other
students have that you can sort of learn
from and so you as an our buckle fellow
lead six students in that first quarter
class and then you switch into
one-on-one coaching for the winter term
and so you actually get assigned three
cochise that you work with each week for
an hour working through all sorts of
topics so it ranges from leadership
topics to how do i balance my life at
the GSB academics and and social and
career to just personal stuff that's
going on so that's been my most
fulfilling activity at the GSB a huge
chunk of time but a really great way to
practice those leadership and coaching
skills that I came here to to work on
awesome Mike how do you spend your time
outside of class or there's particular
clubs that you're really involved with
yeah yeah I can so I can talk to that so
I spent a lot of my time actually
helping TA classes at the GSB especially
in the second year and it's actually one
of the things that I've personally found
and a most rewarding about the Stanford
experience which is that so much of the
learning that happens here happens
because we have just incredible
classmates who come from all types of
different backgrounds and so because I
have a finance investing background I
have spent a lot of my time this year
helping to of the finance professors
here teach classes TA classes develop
case material and that that's sort of
been my big commitment outside of
regular coursework and it's something
that I do because I think you know one
it's it's good practice in terms of
learning how to be a leader not to
communicate how to teach people but at
the same time it's it's allowed me to
give back to the community that I think
has already given me a lot over the past
two years
in terms of the the split between times
spent on different activities I would
say it varies pretty dramatically so
it's very hard to say you know what the
average is because it's very
unrepresentative of the variance is very
large and so I would say that the great
thing about the GSP is that if you come
there is no structure to which you have
to adhere if you want to spend a lot of
time on academics and I know I feel like
I've probably indexed on that relatively
more heavily than some of our classmates
then you can do that if you want to
spend more of your time on
extracurriculars more of your time on
even social activities that's that's
completely accepted and and even
encouraged at Stanford so I think it's
really hard to say what a typical GSB
student looks like because there is no
typical GSB student like everyone has
different priorities and all those
priorities are welcomed by the community
so we've talked about learning in the
classroom could each of you talk about
one of the global experiences or maybe
multiple that you've been involved with
and how that's shaped your GSB
experience sure yeah so I participated
in a GST so a global study trip to
Thailand last winter and so the global
study trips are led by second years so
we were I was a first year at the time
so we were taken to Thailand by five
second years who totally crafted the
experience and chose to look at the
country through food so we studied the
sort of the food supply chain in
Thailand we looked at we visited a local
rice paddy but we also looked at went
and visited some of the largest
conglomerates that are actually
packaging and and just distributing all
over the world and so we just had a
chance to explore a new culture meet
with all sorts of people again from
someone running their own small shop to
someone running a huge conglomerate and
we're able to do it together so it was
definitely for me I thought
it allowed me to see the country in a
whole new way because we were very on
the ground and and sort of seeing it
from all these different angles but also
it really allowed me to forge incredible
friendships through just by being in a
country in a totally new place with
folks that I didn't know super well
before the trip and so I think I left
with a whole new appreciation for the
country of Thailand but also for a lot
of my classmates who I may not have
otherwise gotten to know yeah I had a
similar experience
the trip that I remember most vividly is
actually one that was organized by our
classmates to India and we spent about
10 days there met with everyone ranging
from political leaders to small business
owners to executives at larger
corporations and learn a lot about India
developed a new sense of appreciation
for the amount of growth and potential
in the country I think that stuff is you
know you can get that stuff just like
going to different countries and
traveling on your own what's what's
really unique about the trips that you
take at the GSB to these countries is
that you're going with classmates I
think something like 40% of our class is
international students and so you know
in all these countries the people who
are leading you the people who are
showing you the country are people from
those places who either grew up there
went to school there or worked there and
have incredible networks and just an
incredible depth of understanding of
those places and I think that's what's
really unique about these trips you know
it's not the fact that you can go all
over the world it's the fact you can go
with someone who knows those places
intimately and that's been the most I
think meaningful part of the
international experience for me at the
GSB
yeah our trip leader to Thailand
actually was from Thailand and so we had
big family dinners with her family who
live over there and got to see meet
leaders who we would we would not
otherwise have had access to so I think
that's a a really good point about
seeing the country through someone's
eyes who's actually experienced it day
to day yeah
great so some of the exploration happens
through global experiences I think a lot
of self-exploration also happens at the
GSB and when you think about exploring
your career opportunities have you used
any specific resources at Stanford to
help you navigate that kind of
exploration I know you mentioned
possibly doing a career change so how
has that been influenced by the GSB and
opportunities through the MBA program
yeah I would say for me it was mostly
those informational interviews that has
shaped that again the access to the
online alumni network also we have a
fantastic Career Center so I basically
took those informational interviews had
like two buckets that I wanted to focus
on for my summer internship and and for
longer term and the Career Center pulled
up a whole nother list of alums in those
spaces helped me think through a
timeline to actually think about trying
different things during the year and I'm
actually doing an internship so as I
mentioned I'm joint degree student in
Edden and in business and I'm actually
doing an internship with Stanford
undergrads with what through the res
life Department to explore that higher
opportunity so that that's possible you
get course credits through through the
GSB so I'm actually getting credit for
that internship and so you don't just
have the the summer experience to
explore this career change but you also
have time throughout the year I have
classmates who have started companies
I've cost me to have done three 90s with
what we call three 90s similar to this
experience with res ed and because we
have access to Silicon Valley a lot of
folks are you know pitching VCS and and
working working their day to day so I
think those both the alumni network the
Career Center and this internship
day-to-day have really helped me
solidify how to make that change and
whether I want to make that change
okay you touched on something that we
also have a question about which is GSB
location and Mike I don't know if this
has come into your thought process for
recruiting or kind of the more formal
channels at the GSB at you
gotten a sense of how our location and
Silicon Valley is either expanded
opportunities or the challenges that
might come with being on the west coast
sure well I think um so I have a
personal bias towards the west coast
I've been here for yeah almost ten years
and so that was actually a huge selling
point for me for those of you who may
not have been here the weather here is
pretty awesome I would say that
certainly if you know you're you're in
Palo Alto but your desired industry and
company and firms are in New York City
there's no question that that becomes
logistically more difficult you know
flying six hours out to New York flying
back is is more challenging than for
students at some of our peer schools on
the East Coast that doesn't mean however
that those firms aren't interested in
GSB graduates in fact you know a lot of
the demand a lot of the job
opportunities available through the CMC
are from New York employers and so the
the downside to the geography is not
limited access it's actually just
logistical difficulty mm-hmm and that's
something I found when I was
interviewing in New York I was
interviewing with some investment firms
and just flying out there was the most
painful part but it wasn't hard to get
them to be interested in GSB grads in
terms of obviously the benefit is if
you're interested in industries that are
more centered around the bay area you
know biotech information technology
obviously then there is I think the
access and the logistical ease is pretty
unparalleled so it really depends on
what you want but I guess what I would
emphasize is that you know access is
incredibly broad and that that the one
commitment you'd have to make is to
undergo some more logistical challenges
and flying back and forth yeah building
off that I think I I did recruit on the
on the East Coast full-time and I think
two things that actually helped in being
out here surprisingly one is that we
have really long breaks so I would use
those breaks
you network with folks in New York
and really set up in informational
interviews and interviews during those
those periods so you do have yes
logistical nightmares during the school
year but if you're really strategic and
smart about how you use your time off
Stamford gives you a ton of time off to
be able to fly to other places and then
the second thing is I think you're
actually it recruiters are I think a
little bit more surprised to get emails
from folks on the west coast about East
Coast jobs and you know jobs in Chicago
and jobs in Texas and things like that
so I think you actually have or I found
that I actually had somewhat of an
advantage because I was they were like
how would you why would you want to
leave California and so I I found myself
actually I'm recruiting with a smaller
pool of people and so I think yes you do
have the access if you want to stay in
California but if you don't I think both
the the availability of breaks to to
network and then also the fact that most
people do choose to stay in California
you you have your you're a bit of an
anomaly you actually have some increased
opportunity as a result and I think also
the size of our program relatively
compared to the number of opportunities
on the East Coast it's just a
supply-demand perspective there's so few
people I think relatively in the larger
scheme that it creates a supply-demand
advantage for our student body and you
brought up a really good example even
with your significant other working in
real estate in New York having access to
our alums so I also think about networks
more broadly than geography I think a
lot about networks in 2016 kind of being
informational networks and access to
people who really have deep expertise
and I think so much of that I mean of
course you want contextual knowledge but
also learning about the access to
information that you have through our
alums can really cross borders and time
zones pretty easily these days and for
sure so well logistics can be a
challenge we also have a question about
challenges in general at Stanford and
someone's asking us what has been your
most difficult experience at Stanford
it's a head-scratcher sure so I I'm
actually at Stanford with my partner and
we we applied at the same time we were
both really fortunate to be admitted and
and she's also an MBA too and the
biggest challenge for us just on a
personal level was just in the beginning
the the GSB is so all-consuming in terms
of its demands on your time from the
academics to the to the social scene to
you know you're thinking about jobs and
internships and should I start a
business etc etc and I think the biggest
challenge for us and a source of
friction in our relationship in those
early days coming to the GSB was how
much time you know do we spend on
spending time with each other versus on
these other priorities that we have
because we do want to go through the
transformative experience that the GSB
has to offer
and I think it generalizes to a broader
point for me it manifested itself in my
relationship with my significant other
you know I think for people who don't
have partners here that the
generalization is that you know you have
your personal life you have your life
that you lead before the GSB and now you
have these massive time commitments that
are put on you by the GSB and the
question of how you balance those two
can be fraught with uncertainty and can
cause frictions with with with your
relationships with people before before
you came I think everyone I know has has
successfully worked through those my
partner and I were able to you know find
the right balance but in the beginning
that can be a really big challenge
mm-hmm yeah and just building off of
that I think I think my biggest
challenge was the transition Fall
Quarter as well for slightly different
reasons I think I came in knowing what I
wanted to focus on but the second you
get here you're exposed to so much and
you're exposed to so many different
classmates and you hear about a company
that someone's been at and you're like
wow that sounds interesting maybe I'll
add a third industry to look at and so I
think for me
it was really figuring out how do I
learn to say no to things and be
comfortable getting out of the
experience what I came here to get out
and so I would say the the more clear
you can be about what you want from
Business School and the closer you can
stick to that when you're here the
easier that adjustment is but I would
say yeah that the first quarter at the
GSB there there's a lot going on and
there's a lot of opportunity it's really
critical to focus on what you decided
you wanted to get out of the experience
yeah that's perfect I really appreciate
you adding some advice in there because
I was gonna ask if you had any final
tips so that's really great words to
live by not just for the application but
I think for life mic'd any final
thoughts on tips coming into either
applying to or attending the GSB yeah
absolutely
so my final word of advice for the
guests who are watching over the
Internet is that a lot of the admissions
process and even the GSB process itself
if you haven't been a part of if you
have experienced that yet it can seem
contrived it can seem like what what is
what do they actually mean by you know
being introspective and being reflective
like aren't those aren't those just buzz
words right and and what I would say is
they can be and they can be and that
that only happens if you don't truly
kind of buy in if you don't truly commit
yourself to being reflective right to
thinking about why have you made the
decisions you did being honest about
that being honest about where you're
from who you are what your goals are
instead of you know what you think that
society or admissions officers want to
see from you or if you're admitted what
you think your peers or your professors
want to see from you the only way you
really get to experience the GSB x'
benefits at a true level of depth is is
when you buy in is when you say I am
going to do these things even though it
feels kind of awkward and cheesy at
first I am gonna reflect I am gonna
think about my life as it's been so far
and
what I hope for it to be like in the
future so that would be my my final word
advice and the the buzzword that I would
use to capture that is be authentic be
authentic to yourself those are great
tips both for the application and for
life I wanted to thank you both so much
for taking the time I know you always
have 50 things you could be doing I mean
half hour of the day so I really
appreciate it and you really brought the
GSB to life so thank you so much all of
you that are joining us I want to thank
you for your time as well really
appreciate you taking the time to learn
more about the MBA program as a reminder
you can always learn more about the GSB
on our website and we'll also be on the
road this summer so if you want to learn
more about Stanford in person you can
take a look at our event calendar online